il ya gaumont qui viennent me voir et
qui me qui me pose une question à
thierry je sais pas quand mais très peu
d acteurs et qu'on te dit qu'est ce que
tu as envie de jouer si tu te rends
compte qu'on me demande ça donc c'est un
truc de dingue ça donc je me retrouve là
dedans je mets pas beaucoup parlent de
répondre lui pas parce qu'en fait quand
un acteur lui pincer le personnage hiver
il ya tout il ya tout dedans tu peux
être un peu dans le drame
tu peux tu peux être léger marrant il ya
de l'action vu tout ce que j'ai traversé
ces dernières années en tant qu'acteur
j'ai touché un peu à tout ces trucs là
si je peux le faire avec le même
personnage et pendant longtemps tu vois
puisqu'on est dans une série c'est la
récré idéal c'est le jouet de le jouer
père fait le jouet parfait c'est à dire
que si tu es anglais tu dit james bond
quand tu es français tu dis lupin tu
vois ce que je veux dire donc ça vient
comme ça en fait il me demande ce que je
veux faire je leur parle de lupin ils
disent ok et pis c'est parti on se met à
développer lupin et et après s'en suit
ce qui s'en suit on en est là mais mais
ça part comme ça en fait et lupin parce
que ouais c'était dit cité anglais tu
dit james bond direct et puis français
on a lui pincer un personnage incroyable
[Musique]